premier jour où il prononce son discours à
la fête, je sais que nous étions tous
impatients d'être le public et juste de
regarder et de le regarder jouer
et c'était vraiment excitant oui c'était vraiment
bon et vraiment intimidant et j'étais
emmêlé dans  cordes Spader savait ce qu'il
faisait et il y est allé malgré tout
parce qu'il pensait que si je devais le faire,
laissez-moi vraiment le faire,
c'est terrible de nous mettre sur un plateau
ensemble, je veux juste que tout le monde sache
que maintenant s'est présenté au  studio et
ils m'ont mis dans un costume et ils m'ont fait passer
par une gamme de mouvements et de mouvements très spécifiques
et ainsi de suite
qu'ils ont capturés avec toutes ces sortes de
capteurs partout sur moi et des
caméras de référence tout autour de moi et en 10
minutes le genre  d'une image approximative d'
Ultron était sur un écran à surveiller
devant moi je t'ai dépassé Tony j'ai
évolué la capture de performance est
toute la performance donc vous filmez
le rôle entier d'un acteur il se trouve que
c'est un groupe de caméras différent  mais le
un  La nuance réelle est que tous les choix d'acteur que
vous créez se déroulent exactement de
la même manière que vous le feriez si vous
jouiez une action en direct, lui et moi devons faire
des choses, vous savez que c'est ridicule de
porter ces costumes très peu flatteurs
et je '  J'essaie de leur expliquer vous
savez comment tout cela fonctionne mais j'étais comme si je
travaillais avec le changement Boehner regarde toi
Ruffalo tu aimes vraiment en tirer un sur
le monde après juste une
Odyssée espagnole numérique bicolore Darla même
concept Alma ou  brune quelle est la vraie
activité VD nous sommes au centre commercial